je suis indigné je suis révolté en tant
que maman en tant que maman policière
oser s'attaquer à un enfant parce qu'il
a ce la paix des huîtres et des
crevettes lors d'un repas familial le 25
décembre
oui oui c'est je répète c'est des
huîtres et des crevettes
est-ce que des huîtres et des crever de
s'associer à noël pourquoi en fait on
s'interroge on comprend en fait on est
stupéfait en ma famille et moi même on
ne comprend pas en fait
pourquoi de telles agressions pour pour
pour avoir zappé des huîtres et des
crevettes
aujourd'hui donc et votre fils et se
porte bien
il se porte bien il est il reste choqué
il a des courbatures il a des céphalées
il a des hématomes au visage et au dos
et
et c'est surtout que voilà tout
toutes les personnes me demandent si
c'est lui qui a été victime de cet acte
oui c'est plus le je pense la fierté on
a pris un coup
à 20 ans se faire tabasser par quatre
personnes se faire lâcher
m il a été mis à terre et tabassé pour
ça en fait c'est dégueulasse c'est
dégueulasse
importante alors je voudrais que nos
enfants les enfants des fonctionnaires
de police les enfants des forces de
l'ordre soient tout simplement protégé
on ne s'attaque pas aux enfants des
policiers et des forces de l'ordre
il est hors de question je remercie
d'ailleurs les collègues du commissariat
de belfort qui ont été très réactifs et
qui ont immédiatement saisi cette
affaire et qui a été grandement mener